we are from bologna the capital of pasta
yeah capital of ragu lasagna
tortellini everything
[Music]
we heard about a lot about olive garden
like a lot of italians complaining about
it so pretty famous in the opposite way
i never tried it i'm pretty curious
about it because i
actually don't know what to expect so
yeah i'm seriously
curious about it curious there are
things in the menu that
doesn't even exist in italian
language or italian menus anywhere like
fettuccine alfredo or
what is this
i don't really know
how i'm gonna swallow even a fork of it
without a quarter of liter of red wine
pasta looks gummy already to me and of
course that's the only thing i'm really
afraid of is yeah overcooked pasta
is actually not that bad so no no no no
i don't know it's it smells like the
normal sugars you you buy at the at the
same time
this is what we have to do mix it
you want to eat it okay
[Music]
it's not bad as i expected
no actually it
may be
weird it could be like really really
worse
but it's not that bad
[Music]
why are they
shiny and oily like this
i can beat you with that
don't play with
bread is a really big deal in italian
bread is a big deal we even fight
between north and south of course
because southern is way better but okay
i'm greasy like everywhere
[Music]
just the aesthetics
not crazy bad
yeah because it's
no i really expect it to be really
anyone would be shocked by
the presentation of the dish and the
text isn't bad really no actually the
taste is not that bad yeah it's just
ugly to see actually
that's the problem the main problem
probably everything is like
double of the size we have in italy
[Music]
is your thing
yeah actually fettuccine is a roman
thing but alfredo is like
i don't know the only alfredo i've ever
known
was a cuban guy actually yeah yeah yeah
i don't know what alfredo could be in
italy alfredo must be some italian guy
that came over here and said okay i can
feed these guys whatever i want i'm
gonna eat that because my name is
alfredo and this is how the dish is born
looks like uh two different
pastas mix it together
there's garlic inside too you see i
don't know
let's try it
pasta pasta
ooh the sourness
the sound that pasta should never
make
the squashy
[Music]
like the pasta you get when you're
really sick and you got to stay at the
hospital or oh no yeah i wouldn't order
it like i i would have done that yeah
yeah we should have tried for sure
because we were sure too so curious
about the alfredo
but it stacks you know well this glue is
this gluey cream helps this is actually
better than the meatballs because
i don't know it's not
much simple looks like more
proper probably i will get killed for
saying something like that when i go low
when i get home but yeah it's actually
more italian than the meatballs yeah
sadly we have to admit that that freddos
are good alfredo must be he knows what
he's doing a really cool guy we do worse
things guys yeah yeah totally
really worst things in my life so it's
not that bad
better than expected for sure
definitely for sure and i'm so ready to
go there in person without feeling
ashamed
and disrespectful to my number i don't
want to make my nonna cry
no open-minded like us yeah
believe me i have troubles even to bring
her to the restaurant in italy because
she's like
that's trash we're gonna eat better at
home and we're leaving everything and
i'm feeling bad because this is really
you know
a bad bad thing to do usually like
leaving the food
sometimes i don't know the cook from
the restaurant you're in just comes from
the kitchen with the dish telling what
we're wrong what were wrong why didn't
you enjoy that insulting you can happen
angry at you because you didn't finish
[Music]